antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir instauration d'un
revenu minimum impôt sur la fortune
les deux projets de loi ont été adoptés
ce matin en conseil des ministres avant
même le débat à l'assemblée nationale à
la rentrée la classe politique
s'interroge vous l'entendrez il faut
dire que ces deux projets constituent
sans doute les dossiers clé de
l'ouverture chiffres et analyses dans
quelques instants
juste après les autres grands titres des
journal de 20 heures
en grèce au lendemain de l'attentât
trois hommes et une femme porteurs de
passeports de pays arabe recherché par
la police
la jeune française dont la photo a été
diffusée hier vient d'être mise hors de
cause
14 juillet 88 synonyme de traditions et
des technologies le mirage 2000
nucléaire sera l'une des attractions du
défilé demain matin au dessus des champs
elysées
le distribuer 20 ans après cette hormone
conseillé aux femmes pour éviter les
fausses couches est à l'origine de
certaines malformations 200 mille
familles sont concernées en france les
jackpots envahissent les casinos
français satisfaction des clients et
sourires des patrons de casinos
car les machines à sous renfloue
véritablement les trésoreries
48 heures seulement après l'attentât
commis à bord d'un bateau de croisière
grecque en mer egée l'enquète
progressent difficilement mais elle
semble s'orienter vers une piste
palestinienne ce matin un membre du
gouvernement grec a indiqué que la
police examiner toutes les hypothèses
il pourrait y avoir des liens avec la
sphère de l'airbus iranien nous vous le
disions des cigares soir ou avec le
procès d'un palestinien qui devait
s'ouvrir aujourd'hui à athènes ce
palestinien arrêté le 1er juin dernier
en grèce est soupçonné d'avoir participé
à un attentat contre un avion de la
panam un avion américain
le point avec notre envoyé spécial
bernard benyamin la morgue du pirée
c'est ici qu'ont été transportées les
victimes du city of ojos c'est ici que
l'on tente depuis hier d'identifier les
corps une tâche extrêmement difficile
parfois impossible dans laquelle le
moindre détail peut être déterminant
vous êtes donc la baisse la belle soeur
du condamné tms le commandant second
tour il a cinq ans
comment s'est passée l'identification
run a trouvé seulement sa main droite
avec la bad et c'est grâce donc à cette
bague
quant à pékin prologue et sept et louis
à travers ce témoignage vous aurez
compris pourquoi l'identification est
tellement complexe
pourquoi en particulier on ne sait pas
avec certitude si oui ou non il y a des
français parmi les victimes du bateau en
tout cas la sécurité a été très
sérieusement renforcée dans tous les
aéroports du pays tandis que les
enquêteurs n'écartent aucune piste a
priori ainsi la revendication cet après
midi d'un groupe palestinien lié
semble-t-il à abou nidal et étudier
sérieusement mais pour le moment on
refuse à athènes de se prononcer sur
cette hypothèse
la police grecque qui est aidé dans
cette affaire par les services secrets
américains recherchent toujours deux
hommes tous deux en possession d'un
passeport libanais le premier aurait
participé à l' attaque du city au port
hausse le second serait le propriétaire
de la voiture qui a explosé au pirée
quelques heures avant la tête du bateau
heures d'antenne ne vous avons montré
les photos de deux personnes présentées
par la police grecque comme étant
susceptibles d'avoir participé à
l'attentât
ces photos prises sur le bateau juste
avant la catastrophe avait été distribué
dans les ports dans les aéroports et
dans les postes frontières grecques sur
l'une de ses photos envoyées notamment
une jeune fille de 21 ans et isabelle
bismuth ses parents qui habitent dans la
région parisienne ont confirmé sa
présence en grèce mais ils sont
catégoriques
elle n'a rien à voir avec la sphère des
terroristes affirmation confirmée ce
soir par la sûreté grecque et par un
autre témoignage capital que nous venons
d'enregistrer au téléphone en quête de
bruno gex un simple cliché ce qui aurait
pu ne rester qu'un souvenir de vacances
a métamorphosé pendant quelques heures
isabelle miss mute en terroriste
international ce soir les autorités
grecques démentent
elle n'est pas impliquée dans l'attentât
affirment les policiers c'est donc dans
la précipitation dans la confusion la
plus totale que ces derniers ont fait
diffuser le portrait d'isabelle dans le
monde entier
elle était devenue l'un des principaux
suspects dans la tuerie du city of poros
tout cela sur la foi de quelques
passagers qui ont affirmé l'avoir
reconnu porteuse d'un passeport marocain
selon les autorités grecques et déjà
répertorié comme individu dangereux
toujours selon ces mêmes autorités
incroyable nous sommes tous restés
devant la télévision en train de
regarder à crier envoyons notre fille
surtout quand celle-ci nous disait que
notre fille était marocaine et et qui
étaient terroristes
incroyable isabelle a peut-être ici même
fait une rencontre fortuite
une chose est sûre elle était
accompagnée d'une amie rose anna torelli
cette dernière a été interrogée par
l'ambassade de france à athènes
elle vient de donner de ses nouvelles
elle parle notamment de la rencontre
d'isabelle bismuth avec les terroristes
sur le bateau vous étiez avec isabelle
bismuth est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles d'isabelle où il ajoute tout
que pour l'instant la précision est
importante isabelle ne fait partie
d'aucune liste n'est pas sur la liste
des décédés elle n'est pas sur la liste
des disparus
le consulat de france à athènes et
évidemment à sa recherche
là je vous rappelle le dernier bilan de
la catastrophe neuf morts 80 blessés
parmi eux plusieurs dizaines de français
certains ont déjà regagné l'hexagone à
bord d'avions spéciaux d'autres sont
attendus dans les minutes qui viennent
notamment à roissy charles de gaulle à
la suite des événements survenus en
grèce le ministère de l'économie et des
finances rappelle à toutes les personnes
victimes d'actes de terrorisme à
l'étranger qu'elles peuvent bénéficier
d'une indemnisation pour de plus amples
renseignements il faut téléphoner aux 43
74 11 90 je vous rappelle ce numéro de
téléphone
le 43 74 11 90 politique après les
hommes de l'ouverture voici les dossiers
clé de l'ouverture ce matin en conseil
des ministres le gouvernement a présenté
les deux projets de lois qui vont sans
doute dominer la vie politique française
dans les mois à venir
d'un côté lisf l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune
de l'autre le
revenu minimum d'insertion un coup
d'oeil sur les textes en compagnie de
claire chazal et de christophe martet
ensuite nous évoquerons les enjeux
politiques
cet homme possède un patrimoine de plus
de 4 millions de francs il devra
acquitter le nouvel impôt sur la fortune
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
devrait concerner environ 120 milles
personnes comme en 1982 ne seront axés
ni les oeuvres d'art ni les forêts
l'outil de travail reste lui aussi
exonérés dès lors que le chef
d'entreprise possède plus de 25 % de sa
société les to sont plus faibles qu'en
82 ils s'échelonneront progressivement
de 0 5% à 0 9%
un exemple le propriétaire d'un château
de 4 millions de francs devra payer 20
mille francs par an au fisc lisf devrait
rapporter environ 4 milliards de francs
à l'état cet impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune doit financer en partie pour la
moitié environ
le revenu minimum d'insertion ce sont
les préfets qui distribueront ce revenu
aux cinq cent mille français les plus
pauvres une personne seule touchera 2000
francs par mois auxquels pourront
s'ajouter mille francs pour une autre
personne du ménage et 600 francs par
enfant à charge
le gouvernement a donc abattu ses cartes
aujourd'hui mais la véritable bataille
ne se déroulera qu'à l'automne devant le
parlement
quelle sera l'attitude des barriste le
premier ministre ne risque-t-il pas
d'être prise en tenaille entre les
exigences des députés communistes par
exemple et la main tendue par certains
santis centriste difficile à dire seul
élément de réflexion les premières
réactions que nous avons enregistré
aujourd'hui les voisines l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes ou l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune puisque c'est
pratiquement le même impôt c'est un
mauvais impôt on en a vu les effets
néfastes
en dise la partie 1982 jusqu'en 1986 sur
l'immobilier en particulier et sur
l'emploi en général c'est un impôt qui
alourdit la fiscalité du capital en
france qui est déjà très lourde et c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre groupe va
se battre pendant la discussion de ce
texte pour essayer d'en obtenir un
un allègement que ce serait de ne pas
créer un impôt de plus si le
gouvernement pour des raisons
idéologiques s'acharne autre démarche
sera la suivante vous créer un impôt de
plus il faut en vc-1 qui existaient déjà
et je prends un seul exemple les droits
de succession ce sont des impôts qui se
sont beaucoup alors dit faut en profiter
pour les remettre à plat et les baisser
en particulier sur les petites et
moyennes succession compte tenu du
triplement des fortunes depuis 1982 ils
font un rendement beaucoup plus
important de l'ordre de 20 milliards
pour pouvoir financer les mesures contre
la pauvreté
d'autre part nous considérons que on
peut moduler l'impôt dans un sens de
réduction du taux lorsqu'il s'agit
d'investissements qui créent des emplois
et des capacités productives mais par
contre il faut un taux nettement plus
élevé pour des fortunes qui sont placés
dans la spéculation et dans les
placements financiers en tout genre moi
je dirais que la présentation du texte
tel quel et me paraît un minimum tant
par être le plancher où il y eu je pense
que si discussions à dieu elle pourra
avoir une éventuellement sur un
rendement supérieur
voilà je vous rappelle que la promesse
de créer un revenu minimum d'insertion
financé par un impôt frappant le capital
avait été faite par françois mitterrand
lui même pendant la campagne
présidentielle
alors question philippe celle ci on a
l'impression ce soir que tout le monde
et est mécontent a entre guillemets à
droite on dit que le gouvernement va
trop loin
à gauche on pense que le gouvernement
est parfois trop timide bref les preuves
du parlement risque d'être difficile
dans les mois qui viennent en tout cas
c'est ce que disent certains experts qui
appartiennent à des cabinets
ministériels de l'actuel gouvernement
qui affirme qu'il est difficile de
transformer un cactus au bouquet de
fleurs et nombreux en effet sont ceux
qui comptent les épines soit parce que
ils les trouvent trop aiguë soit trop
émoussés les premiers rappelle que le
capital en france supporte déjà l'impôt
foncier les droits de mutation des taxes
sur les plus-values les droits de
transmission et avec ce nouvel impôt la
france dit il suit le chemin inverse de
celui de ses partenaires qui veulent
abaisser la pression fiscale
à l'inversé second affirme que les taux
proposés sont
bien trop timide et que l'exclusion de
l'outil de travail des oeuvres d'art du
projet lui ôte beaucoup de son caractère
de justice sociale pour le gouvernement
la tâche est rude il s'agit de faire
cohabiter une décision fiscale tricolore
avec la décision européenne de libre
circulation des capitaux
c'est à dire dans deux ans de choisir
librement où placer ses économies dans
la communauté on s'attend donc à la
rentrée à de rudes discussions et ne
pluie d'amendements à l'assemblée et le
gouvernement devra probablement choisir
entre ceux des centristes
est ce les communistes merci philippe la
hausse des prix au mois de juin +0 3% un
chiffre moyen sont plus qui sera
officialisé dans les jours qui viennent
par les services de l'insee pour les
douze derniers mois la hausse des prix
vous le voyez atteint 2 6% nous voisins
allemands en sont pour l'instant à 1,1
pour cent à la hausse bien sûr nouvelle
question philippe sassier est ce que
pierre bérégovoy le ministre de
l'économie et des finances va pouvoir
tenir son pari
2 5% qui était également le pari fait
par monsieur balladur
c'est par là ça sert et que certains
instituts de conjoncture et film ce sera
difficile de ne pas dépasser 2 5 %
l'insee estime à 3 3 1% la hausse
maintenant pierre bérégovoy a dit que
s'il n'y avait pas de dérapage du dollar
et du prix du pétrole il pourrait tenir
cet engagement qui suit également de son
prédécesseur et par ailleurs il n'a pas
caché dans une interview publiée par le
figaro hier qu'il était très attentif à
cette un dérapage des prix et que le cas
échéant comme les textes de 1986 claude
la possibilité il pourrait revenir sur
cette liberté des prix qui a été donnée
à certains services
merci philippe attendons tout au moins
pour le moment françois mitterrand rend
hommage à pierre bourdan l'un des
maîtres à penser at il dit de la
libération et de l'après-guerre en
france c'était cet après midi à paris le
chef de l'état a rappelé que pierre
bourdan disparu accidentellement il ya
40 ans était avec lui l'un des plus
jeune ministre du premier gouvernement
de la quatrième république
hommage rendu au ministère des dom tom
au micro d'olivier werner le président
de la république a évoqué l'accord rpcr
fln ks au sujet de la nouvelle calédonie
écoutez le est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
votre façon à vous de célébrer
finalement ces retrouvailles entre
le rpc à leurs fans qui n'ont que je
suis
très important
peut-être même déterminant
je suivis avec vous connaîtrez
évolution heureuse que cette situation
dramatique
dans le sens mais moi-même chic c'est en
souhaitant le retour au dialogue mais
c'est un problème important parmi
d'autres à la veille du 14 juillet
françois mitterrand vient d'adresser un
traditionnel message aux armées le chef
de l'état exprime sa confiance aux
militaires dont il salue je cite le sens
du service de l'état et l'amour de la
patrie 14 juillet en fanfare demain sur
notre chaîne sur antenne 2 à partir de
9h50 exactement vous pourrez suivre le
traditionnel défilé du 14 juillet sur
les champs elysées les deux réalisateurs
jean luc léridon et alexandre tartas
disposeront tenez vous bien de treize
caméras pour vous permettre de suivre
l'événement en direct
le commentaire sera assurée par patrick
lecocq mobilisation exceptionnelle pour
un défilé placé sous le double signe de
la technologie et de la tradition eric
monier en plein défilé
la panne moteur à l'entraînement même
l'imprévu est envisagée le char est
contournée par les autres blindés durant
toute l'opération une seule idée fixe
rendre l'incident le moins visible
possible
c'est sur une piste désaffectée de la
base aérienne de villacoublay que
s'effectuent les répétitions de toute la
partie motorisé du défilé là nous soigne
les détails on peaufine pour
l'état-major c'est une question
d'honneur
toutes ces manoeuvres sont envisagées
comme une véritable opération militaire
radio en quatre jours l'exercice en
grandeur réelle sera répétée une dizaine
de fois le temps pour les pilotes de
prendre la cadence des 15 kilomètres
heures du défilé
quant à la machine elle est confiée aux
hommes de l'ombre
le détachement des mécaniciens une
centaine d'hommes capables d'intervenir
sur tous les types d'engins bugs et si
la panne est trop grave chaque type de
véhicule à son double qui peut le
remplacer à tout moment
c'était sur le côté alors c'est pas du
tout gênant pas du tout frustrant c'est
dommage mais on voit ça avec du recul et
c'est assez intéressant
non c'est bon c'est pas grave
autrement on est content d'ailleurs le
compte en effet cif
500 chars et plus de 3000 hommes seront
demain sur les champs elysées tout est
prêt il ne reste plus régiment du
premier corps d'armée qui défileront
demain qui a déployé leurs étendards
devant le président de la république oui
autre précision importante pour antenne
2 pour tous les téléspectateurs de
télématin télématin sera présenté à bord
d'un alphajet demain de la patrouille de
france est dedans il y aura qui bien sûr
bien roger zabel bien sûr dans ciel de
paris demain vous découvrirez le mirage
2000n un mirage porteur du nouveau
missile stratégique français en revanche
vous ne verrez pas le prototype du
rafale qui est le futur avion de combat
de l'armée de l'air le rafale effectué
depuis quelques jours d essais de
présentation d'appontage sur le porte
avions foch reportage françois corner et
jean-marie lequertier porte avions foch
en méditerranée en présentation
d'appontage le rafale avion de combat
véhicules
il ne touche pas encore les roues sur le
pont du porte-avions mais ce qui n'était
hier encore qu'un projet est devenu
aujourd'hui presque une réalité prévu
pour remplacer les vieux cruz adhère de
l'aéronavale française en service depuis
plus de 20 ans le rafale aux côtés du
super étendard sera vraisemblablement
demain le fer de lance de la flotte
embarqué pour l'instant la version
prévue pour l'aéronautique navale
l'acm n'est pas encore muni de sa crosse
d'appontage et n'en est qu'au stade des
essais de présentation finale
ce n'est qu'aux alentours de 1992 qu'un
rafale si cet avion de chez marcel
dassault est définitivement choisi par
la marine à contre a réellement sur un
porte-avions français
ces essais ont lieu alors que
l'aéronavale expriment un besoin urgent
pour conserver sa capacité
opérationnelle notamment sur des
théâtres d'opération éloigné de ses
bases comme l'océan indien par exemple
mais le rafale ne pourrait être embarqué
qu'en 1996 et certains disent qu'il
risque d'arriver trop tard
chacun sait que beaucoup de pilotes très
peu du f 18 américain qui lui est prêt
la faire distribuer rebondit dans les
années 60-70 plusieurs millions de
femmes dans le monde et environ 200
milles en france ont reçu durant leur
grossesse dû distribuer qui est une
hormone de synthèse destinée à éviter
les fausses couches seulement voilà il
apparaît aujourd'hui que ce médicament
était dangereux pour les enfants
directement exposées dans le ventre de
leur mère aujourd'hui le médicament fort
heureusement n'est plus utilisé mais les
effets retard comme on les appelle
commencent à apparaître
pour toute une génération on note par
exemple des problèmes de malformations
en quête d' alain labouze et daniel lévy
astrid à 20 ans béatrice 15 ans et leur
frère yves et 7 ans trois témoins parmi
d'autres des dégâts causés par le
distilbène
tous trois sont atteints de
malformations des organes génitaux leur
mère d'anne avait reçu durant ces
grossesses cette hormone soi-disant
contre les fausses couches
aujourd'hui dan entend regrouper les
deux cent mille femmes qui ont pris du
distilbène
après des années de culpabilité dan a
décidé de faire tomber le tabou
les mamans n'ose pas dire à leurs
enfants et des mamans qui se manifeste
et qui me disent comment je vois faire
est ce que je dois le dire à mes enfants
ou est ce que tu vas pas le dire elle se
culpabiliser toujours et ça il faut
faire tomber ça il faut plus
culpabiliser c'est pas notre faute on a
été des victimes on ne savait pas ce
comprenez on l'a fait confiance déjà
1000 femmes au sein de l'association des
victimes du distilbène
elles ne comprennent pas pourquoi ce
médicament n'a été retiré du marché
qu'en 77,6 ans après les états unis
aujourd'hui outre le risque de
malformations génitales une femme
exposée sur quatre ne parvient pas à
mettre au monde d'enfants vivent les
gynécologues prennent enfin ce problème
au sérieux le collage et les
coquetteries siens a fait une enquête
montrant bien que les conséquences en
france sont les mêmes qu'aux états unis
il faut donc prendre des précautions et
il y a maintenant une liste que nous
avons élaboré deux médecins qui sont
prêts à prendre en charge tout
spécialement ses patientes brochure pour
les médecins projet de résolution au
parlement européen
les choses sont en train de bouger même
si pour hymne pour toi des siemens a
signifié cette opération cette opération
cette opération est chiant
je ne sais pas encore combien les
télégrammes d'actualité comme chaque
soir ils sont commentés par serge me
serait ensuite direction deauville sur
la côte normande à la découverte des
machines à sous cette devise bourg en un
mec fédéral contre une caserne de
l'armée britannique
neuf soldats ont été blessés par des
éclats de verre et un mur en partie
détruit cet attentat a été revendiqué
dès ce matin par l'ira l'armée
républicaine irlandaise
fausse joie pour les policiers
dépresseurs usage dans la cache
découverte ce matin un entrepreneur de
maçonnerie à saint-pée-sur-nivelle dans
les pyrénées atlantiques un matériel
peut être utilisée il ya longtemps par
le thé à une cache morte disent les
policiers
troisième journée de la visite
officielle de mitraille berbatov en
pologne pendant son séjour le numéro un
soviétique n'a pas ménagé son appui au
chef de l'état polonais le général
joseph qui les responsables de
solidarnosc sont déçus commentaire d'un
proche de lech walesa
décidément ce n'est pas encore la
pérestroïka en pologne nicaragua après
l'expulsion de leurs ambassadeurs à
managua les états unis riposte
l'ambassadeur du nicaragua washington
est renvoyée avec cette diplomate
décision annoncée par ronald reagan en
ces termes c'est la réponse du berger à
la bergère dans les casinos et plus
particulièrement sur la côte normande
les machines à sous ont pris un départ
foudroyant vous allez le voir côté
client c'est loin d'être le jackpot à
tous les cours mais tout le monde se dit
très satisfait reste les patrons de
casinos on les entend moins mais pour
eux les machines à sous sont synonymes
de petit pactole en quête de rémy roche
et jean françois bernigaud la mise à un
franc 10 francs sont francs ou même
beaucoup plus en échange une part de
rêve scintillant l'espoir de décrocher
le jackpot et pourquoi pas celui
fabuleux de 1 million de francs bataille
sans merci contre la machine les yeux
dans les yeux clientèle plutôt féminine
souvent au dessus de 40 ans moquette
épaisse décor chic raccompagnement du
client par des hôtesses standing oblige
ici au casino de deauville pas question
de laisser rentrer la mauvaise
réputation des machines à sous car leur
arrivée saluée comme la belle aubaine au
moment où les jeux classiques roulettes
et autres black jack s'essoufflait
le concept concurrentiel nous devons
refaire de la trésorerie jouer notre
rôle d'animateur dans les stations et je
suis persuadé que si nous ne les avions
pas
nous ne les avions pas eu et
si on et développe pas à l'ensemble des
établissements beaucoup d'entre eux
beaucoup parmi eux j'avais
vraisemblablement dans l'obligation de
déposer leur bilan sous de trois ans
machines à sous protêt coulisses des
pièces et des caisses par dizaines de
milliers pesée qu'on paie trier mise en
rouleau il en aura fallu presque 5
tonnes pour mettre en service les 220
machine du casino à côté l'ordinateur
car si la générosité des machines est
laissée à l'appréciation du hasard leur
gestion elle n'a rien de hasardeux
marketing très poussées exemple
l'analyse du bruit des pièces qui
tombent depuis chaque machine
le client donc je vais essayer de voir
ce que va entendre le client quand il va
rentrer par cette porte là il entendra
donc au fond cette machine qui fait
énormément de bruit et en tout premier
lieu il entendra cette machine devant
lui qui fait tout autant de bruit que la
dernière donc la solution la chose que
je devais analyser cette savoir si cette
machine la tire ou me plaît aussi
cette machine la grèce comprend optimale
car finalement l'important ce n'est pas
tant de gagner que d'avoir passé un bon
moment
on y laisse bercer
la chenille surprise sur la route du
tour de france qu'on attendait lucho
herrera c'est un autre colombien fabio
parra qui a fait la différence
aujourd'hui
au terme de la grande étape la première
étape de montagne du tour de france
parra est arrivée seule à morzine
derrière tous les favoris limite les
dégâts sauf jean françois bernard
sean kelly et laurent fignon visiblement
dans un très mauvais jour le résumé de
l'étape
anne mourgues 11e étape la plus longue
la première en montagne dur très dur
laurent fignon peut en témoigner jean
françois bernard aussi aujourd'hui la
grimpe ce n'était pas leur truc c'était
plus celui de l'audio peters le belge
mène la course pendant 200 kilomètres
sous quelles conditions une chaleur
torride le goudron de la route font par
endroits mais la montagne c'est la
sphère des colombiens on attendait
herrera c'est parra qui est apparu à 38
kilomètres de l'arrivée l'homme en vert
s'en va tranquillement tout seul
direction la ligne d'arrivée ils
comptent jusqu'à une minute d'avancé sur
le peloton
un peloton où l'on trouve presque tous
les leaders mottet herrera delgado bauer
peine perdue pas un ne ratera parra
parti tout seul devant
1 4 km de l'arrivée le hollandais de
miss lens bien sprint trop tard parra se
plie dans son rôle de tour aux
solitaires il termine l'étape avec 20
secondes d'avancé sur le second
thierry claveyrolat part à ce signe en
franchissant la ligne d'arrivée
au classement général pas de changement
simon est toujours en deuxième position
de recul 23e
le maillot jaune est toujours sur les
épaules du canadien bawer peut être plus
pour longtemps la montagne fait que
commencer et demain ça sera dur dans le
tour féminin victoire de jeannie longo
devant l'italienne maria à canning longo
canine c'est également l'ordre du
classement général demain deuxième
grande étape de montagne entre morzine
et l'alpe d'huez pour marquer
l'événement le journal de 20 heures
d'antenne 2 sera réalisée en direct de
l'alpe d'huez en compagnie bien sûr de
nombreux invités
la france des festivals ce soir georges
bégoux nous attend en avignon il a vu
pour nous une noce de tchekhov créé par
le chêne noir qui est la troupe
permanente d'avignon les images sans de
gilles dollars
le père alcoolique
la mer à la dérive la fille cupides
le prétendant terrorisé l'univers de
tchekhov est là avec la demande en
mariage la noce et le chant du cygne
souvent un seul titre monte car pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est travailler avec la
parole d'un autre en disant des choses
qui sont les miennes quoi et je crois
que j'ai fait en fait un spectacle moi
qui sut méditerranée j'ai fait un
spectacle ne renieront pas les russes
dans la sensibilité
après je n'ai pas cherché à faire de
l'imagerie je ne travaille pas à moscou
etc
mais je crois pas qu'ils sont
insensibles à cette sensible à cette
folie qui est on à d'islam mais elle est
de tous les endroits de la planète là où
ce vent de folie souffle
après aux vaches et pour vous le prouver
je ferais concept après bonjour vu
naître faux bond aujourd'hui même les
ouvriers faucheron ce prêt mais je les
adore jouer au basket à moi compris à
moi
et
il est vrai des fois peut-être au
festival d'avignon sempiternel mans il
ya des gens qui meurent découvre année
après année comme un petit peu le
régional de l'étape mais ça commence à
bien faire
gérard gélas sa raison son théâtre du
chêne noir a aujourd'hui une vocation
européenne
il joue dans toutes les capitales et son
actuel spectacle l'annoncé coproduit par
une compagnie belge
le succès aidant la culture s'exporte
aussi bien que la haute couture
voilà c'est pratiquement la fin de cette
édition du journal dans quelques minutes
notre laurent cabrol nationale nous dira
tout sur la météo du 14 juillet prochain
rendez-vous d'information 23h35 le
dernier journal sera présenté par hervé
claude demain n'oubliez pas vos rendez
vous habituel 6h45 télématin 13h
l'édition de la mi journée où vous
retrouverez patricia charnolé william
leymergie en direct du centre de taverny
c'est un événement le centre de taverny
c'est le cerveau de notre force
stratégique
je vous retrouve demain à 20 heures en
altitude en direct de l'alpe d'huez sur
la route du tour de france merci de
votre fidélité
bonsoir ya demain
non
m